[Applause]
okay here we are on overtime
okay John the title of your book is the
big lie a line that trump-powered in a
republic and Republicans have
perpetuated how does our nation overcome
this is it even possible
well certainly it is very much still
with us the big lie didn't begin or end
on January 6th Donald Trump planted the
seeds years before he spent years
hijacking the Republican party uh the
conservative media with lie after lie
gave him to believe the big one uh which
is about his false claims election fraud
but we're still seeing it now we've seen
States use it as a republican control
State legislatures use it to restrict
actions about in more than a dozen
states uh we have seen candidates right
now for the midterms not just saying
that they want to still overturn the
2020 election nearly two years out but
won't commit to conceding if they were
to be defeated this fall it is mistach
the Republican party and we're all
seeing the negative impact in the polls
more and more Democrats also feel they
can't necessarily trust election results
uh it is going to be the defining one of
the defining issues for our democracy
these next
this cycle through 2024 and Beyond being
able to restore the American people's
faith in the government they're not
because they have the ability to vote
but their vote will be counted correctly
and that the actual winner is installed
in the power and it is going to take it
is going to take education and it is
going to keep it from both parties
sticking out against it and we're seeing
very little of that certainly for the
Republican side right now
so look I you know had a chapter in my
book dedicated to this I don't disagree
with the premises of your book I will
tell you that it must seem that Stacy
Abrams is a bit of a republican she's
somebody who's running for executive
office top office in Georgia for the
Governor's Mansion who has not yet
conceded the last race who claimed that
that race was stolen from her by Brian
Kemp allegedly one of the same people
who stole the race from Donald Trump
yeah you know I've heard this on the
show before I got to just call [ __ ]
on this yeah
it's like it's like it's just such silly
what about it yes you you pick out the
one example on the left one example
among Democrats that is not nearly as
consequential as what is going on in the
entire Republican party including the
leader of the party Donald Trump and you
that's that's the answer Stacy Abrams
it's a [ __ ] answer man
it's a [ __ ] answer to a giant it's a
giant problem that exists almost
conclusively on one side yeah with all
due respect bill I I will tell you
speaking of somebody who's write a
center
was very clear about the fact that Trump
lost the election and I was disappointed
that he did not accept that result but
it does irritate me a little bit when
people on the left unidirectionally
point the finger at Trump without
looking at take the Iowa election last
time all right Nancy Pelosi refused to
seat somebody or almost refused to see
somebody who was elected out of the
state of Iowa even if you take a lot of
the narratives now as you said impacting
the left
willingness to accept election results I
think it's really important that
everyone who at least points to someone
in their tribe or on the other side
points to someone in their own tribe or
else we're not going to have faith in
either side of the electoral system but
but more so where the the two things are
are more of equal Merit I mean this is a
mouse and an elephant you know it's just
it's it's it's it's a cheapest right I
mean give us for your view on this which
is we're gonna take the 2016 election
all right what role did this play where
a lot of Democrats were not willing to
accept the legitimacy of the 2016
election outcome on the back of the
Russia collusion narrative what role
does that play in giving legitimacy to
the other side to now say they're not
going to accept the election I think
this has been a game of escalation going
along for a long time
election Hillary came down in her purple
suit within before she went to bed
before committing to start the
impeachment hearings on the other side
on the back of a Russia collusion
narrative that impatient was not about
Russia collusion the impeachment was
about Ukraine the impeachment was about
the Ukraine Scandal right there were
certainly Democrats who were unhappy
there were Democrats who certainly were
we saw the protest of women's March the
day after Trump's uh inauguration but
Hillary Clinton can see the election the
next morning yes uh there are there were
even one or two lawmakers who on uh
January the January 6th of of 2017 uh
you know said like oh you know Trump
they're like two lawmakers who suggested
that Trump shouldn't be seated they
might protest and you know who shot them
to set them down Vice President Joe
Biden who was overseeing the Senate that
time said no we're moving on Donald
Trump is elected and you know who shot
down the other side is Mike Pence who
said I'm certifying the results of this
election so I I just think that there
were thousands of people outside trying
to break into the capital like that
right and no one no one is
no one is saying that there aren't
millions and millions of good
Republicans who are not trumpers or
maybe they like Trump but they still
don't think he won the election and they
said so and yes not just Mike Pence
Mitch McConnell Bill Barr
Liz Cheney none of these were on my
favorites list but they did the right
thing they are what I call As Good As It
Gets Republicans you're
I don't know if I'm talking into
liberals now yeah because before the
impeachment trial if you had went down
the list of what Liz Cheney is for I
mean she would be booed rounded by and
now now liberals cheer her because that
is as good as it gets and that's what I
think everybody in this country has to
understand you're never going to get
people who see this the world the way
you do and they don't have to but when
when push came to shove there are
Republicans who did the right thing the
argument you are making is a false
equivalency
this is not a problem on a giant problem
on both sides it is a giant problem on
one side I view it through it I view it
through a Beyond partisan lens okay at
the end of the day well you shouldn't
because it's a partisan issue I I
disagree with that I respectfully
disagree I think there are threats to
democracy I think threats to democracy
are plural for me I'll tell you where
I'm coming from here where I'm coming
from is the best the best measure of the
health of a democracy to me you know
what it is it is the percentage of
people who feel free to say what they
actually think in public it's not the
votes that are cast that's just
fetishizing the act at the end of the
process and when I look at the truth
that's the Democracy to free speech to
open discourse I do not think it is a
one-sided threat from the Republican
party to the contrary I think the
threats to democracy are plural and we
have to acknowledge that or else we're
going nowhere but the votes that cast
do matter because those are putting
people in office who are making public
policy and passing laws and nominating
Justice to the Supreme Court so I mean I
think that's more of an impact also on
personal Liberties than just the ability
to speak out yes and to your point about
other existential threats which both
sides use them both by the way both
sides use the word the phrase big lie
the big lie means a completely different
thing in a trump bar that yes yeah yeah
they think it's made the hoax absolutely
but okay I will agree you know I I'm all
the time getting castigated by people on
the left because I criticize them for
what I think are their excesses let's
show the picture of the lady with the
big tits again
[Applause]
okay but on this particular issue it is
something that only one side really owns
let me ask you this the 147 Michael
Moore was talking about 147 147 members
of Congress who would not certify the
election do you think if it was the
other way around it would have been 147
Democrats who wouldn't certify the
election
do you think the Democrats would have
attacked the capital the way the Trump
people did on January 6. so I don't
think so but I got to tell you that we
also have legitimized crime in a
different sense for the last two years
in this country at the end of the day
we're talking about legitimization and
victim legitimization well at the end of
the day I think a lot of the crime that
we're seeing cities across the country
is because of democratic legitimization
of breaking laws of a different kind now
that's not the threat to democracy point
but I want to come back again it's a
false equivalency yes I mean is it again
I think we're getting nowhere by
pointing partisan fingers I think I
think we are not moving the ball forward
by artisanizing what is a fundamental
erosion of citizens mistrust of our
institution I'm sorry and that's the
problem my compass goes toward what is
true if it points toward partisanship I
have to do it I'm not going to put it
off the table if one side is doing
something and the other isn't now is it
wrong that you can walk into a Walgreens
and shoplift of course it is it's not
that out of the ordinary and it's
eminently fixable and it probably will
be it's a whole different kettle of fish
for from democracy is hanging by a
threat because a lot of people are under
the impression that if they don't win if
they don't get the most amount of votes
it doesn't matter right they're right it
doesn't matter who got the most amount
of votes that's new there are Republican
candidates in the ballot not Democratic
cancer Republic candidates on the ballot
a number of state official elections who
have not said they would they have not
said they would certified election
results they they that were done that
they would find the way to potentially
pick their favorite to be in place
that's that is that is you know
there were Democrats who did not certify
the result of that election so I'm just
saying that this is again another guy
who conceded yeah Al Gore who who had
every reason to stick it out and he
didn't and people and and people in the
center who do not certify the result of
that election but I guess I'm making I'm
making a different point which is that
by fetishizing just the ballots that we
cast at the end every November that's
just the Final Act of the process
there's a lot more to the health of a
democracy than just that it is about
living out the democratic values and I
see the threat to those Democratic
Values coming from Left Right Center but
I think it's a deeper matter of
Institutions crushing the will of
everyday citizens and I think left-wing
populism and right-wing populism are not
as different as we'd like to make them
out to be I think this is a broader
phenomenon it's even transnational of
citizens of Nations feeling like their
voices are not heard or if we see that
through a partisan lens we're missing
the point well all that well we're not
missing the point uh all this a lot of
that is true it has nothing to do with
voting which I don't see as a fetish
well voting is not a fetish
at the end of the day
you know what I think I think a lot of
citizens so let me take a democratic
attack on the legitimacy of Elections
the way the way we're banding about the
word Jim Crow okay at the end of the day
we're applying Jim Crow as a as a label
to asking people to show an idea to vote
my view is that at the end of the day if
you can Google where do I vote at the
end of the day it probably doesn't fit
the Jim Crow label and you know what
Georgia more people are voting this year
than voted before the allegedly voter
suppressive laws that were passed those
are also described into the same Banner
of threats to democracy and I think that
this is
sloppy of a way you're bringing up
appointing to Republicans you're
bringing up a lot of things about the
left which I would agree with where they
have gone off the rails or they're
making some mistake or they're excessive
in one way
all this kitchen sink stuff has nothing
to do with this one thing we're talking
about fundamental democracy voting guy
with the most votes wins and we have to
elect we have to respect that it was
always the jewel in our crown
peaceful transfer of power it's the one
that other countries could not matter so
many other countries had trouble with
this one how do you pass the Baton I
mean I feel like it's not like the
argument I just wrote a book explicitly
calling out Trump and saying that at the
end of the day it was Trump victimhood
that failed the country he lost the
election he should have admitted it and
moved on so I'm not trying to preheat
something I know I was just here but at
the end of the day I think that having
said that it's really important to look
360 degrees it's a lot easier it is to
somebody else than it is again but I
think you're just conflating these two
things there's a lot of craziness on
both sides agreed there's a lot of I
said it all the time I would never vote
for Trump I understand why some people
do I understand my people look at a lot
of the craziness that goes on on the
left and go you know I can't let those
people take over this country because I
have kids and you know what my what my
kids are having to see every day in
school or whatever they're coming home
and telling talking people about and you
know men are pregnant now and you know
just stuff that drives people has
nothing to do with what we're talking
about on this one area of voting and
democracy I agree the left is nuts too
but on this one area they're not the
guilty ones they're not the guilty ones
and it's much more important much more
important
there has been one president yes there
has been one president who did not try
to adhere in the peaceful transfer of
power yes one president once Donald
Trump and one party that is behind him
is still behind him he is still right
now even despite these swirl
investigations and the legal Jeopardy is
in he is still the overwhelming favorite
to be the Republican nominee for
president yes and he will be and he will
probably lose again and it won't matter
because in 2025 he's going to show up on
January 20th to be inaugurated whether
he won that election or not he is
showing up
he's got his suit picked out so it's a
tie I think the time
what do you think the red tie yeah yeah
I think that's I I think he's gonna go
with the red tie so there's a look I
mean I think that in in what I worry
about is each party up in the ante so in
2016 you had a party in power that used
police force to attempt to place a mole
in the campaign of the opposition party
this is
2024 now you have a president in office
that's declaring his enemies at the end
of the day domestic terrorists using
police power to ultimately silence
political opposition you think when the
table's turned that isn't going to
escalate in the other direction you're
going to see Democrats upset about it
when that when that's going to happen I
think it's quite likely to happen that
we continue to play this game of
escalation unless we see this through a
Wednesday these are the rules of the
road it's not a partisan thing it's a
rules of the road question you don't use
power to silence the opposition party
period to me that's the real threat to
democracy I think okay look the White
House is
[Laughter]
you can always pick the raisins out of
the raisin bread but it's mostly a loaf
of bread
I don't even know what that means thank
you very much
for one question